Bienvenidos a Cachemira.
El lugar donde aislarte del mundanal ruido.
Valles sobrecogedores, naturaleza, cultura…
¡¡¡¡Y BOMBAS!!!
Atentados terroristas, bombardeos y violencia
sistemática.
Cachemira es el último lugar donde querrY
en el último mes, esta región situada entre
la India y Pakistán ha vuelto a dar de que
hablar.
Podría ser el inicio de una nueva guerra
nuclear… ¿O tal vez no?
En este vídeo, te lo vamos a contar.
Sólo hay 3 eventos deportivos capaces de
reunir ante las pantallas a más de 1.000
millones de personas en todo el mundo.
Uno es la ceremonia de apertura de unos Juegos
Olímpicos.
Otro es la final del Mundial de Fútbol.
Y el tercero es un India-Pakistán de cricket.
Habéis oído bien: el cricket es el deporte
nacional entre India y Pakistán.
Dos de los países más poblados del mundo…
y dos países que se odian entre ellos.
Y creedme, la rivalidad entre estos dos países
va mucho más allá del deporte.
Cachemira sufre el peor ataque en 30 años
Y no hablamos de una rivalidad menor: tanto
India como Pakistán son potencias nucleares.
Y la manzana de la discordia es una región
que se llama Cachemira.
Ambos países se disputan el control de esta
zona.
En febrero de 2019, un grupo terrorista conectado
con el ejército de Pakistán, Jaish-e-Mohammed
organizó uno de los peores atentados terroristas
en Cachemira.
Y la India respondió con el primera ataque
de la historia en pleno territorio Pakistaní.
La situación no podía ser más tensa ¿Podríamos
estar ante el inicio de una guerra nuclear?
¿Por qué India y Pakistán se llevan tan
mal?
¿Y que son exactamente las doctrinas nucleares?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas,
y lo vamos a hacer junto a mi buen amigo XANDER
SNYDER, que es analista político en RECONSIDER
MEDIA
¡Hola Fonseca y un abrazo a todos los suscriptores
de VisualPolitik!
Pues como dices, continuamos en una situación
de duelo mexicano entre India y Pakistán
pero… ¿Puede llegar a desembocar en una
guerra nuclear?
Lo veo difícil.
Pues bien, hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
FURIA DE TITANES
Tras la segunda Guerra Mundial, todos los
territorios de las Indias se independizaron
del Imperio Británico.
Hasta aquí, todo muy bien, pero había un
problema.
Por estas tierras había dos grandes grupos
religiosos: por un lado había millones de
musulmanes y por el otro millones de hinduistas.
Así que ¿Qué hizo Reino Unido?
Pues muy sencillo: las zonas de mayoría musulmana
pasaron a formar lo que hoy conocemos como
Pakistán y las zonas de mayoría hinduísta,
pasaron a ser lo que hoy conocemos como la
India.
Pero seguía habiendo un problema.
Todavía quedaban zonas grises, con población
de ambas confesiones.
Pues bien, Cachemira era una de esas regiones.
En este caso, los ciudadanos cachemires eran
principalmente musulmanes.
Pero su gobernante, el Maharajá, era hindú.
Así que dijeron: ni Pakistán ni India: Cachemira
independiente y todos contentos ¿verdad?
¡Pues no!
2 meses después de la proclamación de independencia,
Pakistán invadió Cachemira.
Así que el Maharajá pidió ayuda a la India
para frenar la invasión.
Así es como India y Pakistán, que eran estados
recién creados, se enzarzaron en su primera
guerra.
El resultado, además de miles de muertos
y millones de desplazados es que, en el año
1949, Cachemira se dividió en dos mitades:
una para Pakistán y otra para la India.
Pero si pensabais que bastaba con una frontera
para tener contentos a todos… estabais muy
equivocados.
Estos dos países han llegado a tener 3 guerras
por el control de Cachemira.
Las guerras entre India y Pakistán siempre
han sido iguales: las empieza Pakistán y
las gana la India.
A fin de cuentas, son más grandes y tienen
más dinero.
Estamos ya en los años 60.
Por aquel entonces, la primera ministra de
la India era esta mujer que veis en pantalla:
INDIRA GANDHI.
Y hay dos cosas que debéis saber de esta
mujer; ni tenía nada que ver con Mahatma
Gandhi ni tenía nada que ver con la paz.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esta es la mujer
que decretó la vasectomía forzosa para 6
millones de hombres pobres.
Así.
Por las buenas.
Así que, un buen día, la señora Gandhi,
viendo que los pakistaníes no dejaban de
tocar las pelotas, dijo “a tomar por culo…
¡BOMBA ATÓMICA!”
En el año 1967, India comenzó su programa
atómico.
Desde entonces, el ejército de Pakistán
no se atrevió a volver a atacar a toda una
potencia nuclear.
En su lugar, los habitantes de Cachemira han
sufrido continuos ataques terroristas por
parte de grupos pakistaníes.
Y si los terroristas no son suficiente, el
gobierno de la India tampoco se anda con paños
calientes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde 1990,
Cachemira está bajo leyes militares.
Osea, que la represión es contínua.
Pero si pensábais que la situación no podía
ser más complicada, estáis muy equivocados.
En el año 1998, las cosas cambiaron… a
peor.
DUELO MEXICANO
Enfrentarse a un país nuclear es como salir
a jugar al cricket sin bates.
Por eso, aunque Pakistán aún más pobre
que la India, Zulfikar Ali Bhutto, presidente
de Pakistán, lo tuvo muy claro.
“Comeremos hierba u hojas, incluso pasaremos
hambre, pero conseguiremos una” - Zulfikar
Ali Bhutto
Y así es como, en el año 1998, Pakistán
realizó sus primeras pruebas nucleares.
Pakistán ha sido obligada a ejercer la opción
nuclear debido al reconocimiento del programa
nuclear de la India.
Esto ha llevado al colapso de la disuasión
existencial y ha alterado radicalmente el
equilibrio estratégico en nuestra región.
Y así es como llegamos a la situación de
duelo mexicano.
Un duelo mexicano es un enfrentamiento en
el que los oponentes están en igualdad de
condiciones.
De este modo ambos están sin actuar, esperando
que un elemento externo influya y la balanza
se decante hacia un lado para empezar a actuar.
Ahora bien, aunque India y Pakistán tengan
bombas atómicas, hay una diferencia muy grande
entre ambos países: las doctrinas nucleares.
La India tiene una doctrina de "no primer
uso".
Esto significa que solo está dispuesta a
usar su arsenal nuclear si es atacada previamente
con armas nucleares.
Pakistán tiene una doctrina diferente.
Ellos están dispuestos a usar su arsenal
nuclear si son invadidos.
Es decir, que aunque India no les lance bombas
atómicas, Pakistán sí podría usarlas.
Y en esta doctrina, juegan un papel fundamental
las llamadas armas tácticas.
Dentro de las armas nucleares podemos hablar
de dos tipos: las más potentes, son las estratégicas,
que pueden destruir grandes ciudades y se
pueden mandar a miles de kilómetros de distancia.
Las otras son las armas tácticas, diseñadas
para ser utilizadas en un campo de batalla.
Pues bien, el pasado enero Pakistán probó
sus misiles NASR, lo que provocó titulares
como éste:
Pakistán equipa a los militares con misiles
tácticos con capacidad nuclear
En otras palabras, Pakistán compensa su menor
poderío militar con una doctrina nuclear
más agresiva.
Podrían utilizar las armas tácticas contra
cualquier movimiento invasor y las estratégicas
contra los silos nucleares indios.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¡Menuda
doctrina nuclear más irresponsable!
¿verdad?
Pues esperad porque todavía no habéis visto
nada.
El botón nuclear de Pakistán no está en
manos del Gobierno sino del ejército.
Y resulta que, en Pakistán, el Gobierno va
por un lado y el Ejército y los servicios
de inteligencia van por el otro.
Eso explica que los terroristas campen a sus
anchas por Pakistán, muchas veces apoyados
por sus propias fuerzas armadas.
Y eso explicaría también la relación de
amor odio con Estados Unidos.
El Ejército de Estados Unidos cancela 300
millones de dólares en ayuda a Pakistán
a causa de los grupos terroristas
Lo cierto es que hay razones de sobra para
desconfiar del ejército de Pakistán ¿Os
acordáis de Osama Bin Laden?
¿Recordáis dónde lo encontraron finalmente?
¡Exacto!
En Pakistán.
Más concretamente, al lado de la Academia
Militar de Kakul, que es como el West Point
pakistaní.
¿Y qué tipo de grupos terroristas están
conectados al ejército?
Pues… básicamente, lo mejor de cada casa.
Por un lado tenemos a los yihadistas que apoyan
a los talibanes en Afganistán.
Pero también hay otros grupos como Jaish-e-Mohammed,
que luchan por la independencia de Cachemira.
Así que da igual si el gobierno de Islamabad
y el de Nueva Delhi intentan llevarse bien.
Tanto el ejército pakistaní como los terroristas
se encargan de torpedear todas las posibles
negociaciones.
¿Y qué hace la India al respecto?
Pues mejorar continuamente su arsenal nuclear
¿Qué haces cuando tu vecino puede atacar
tus silos nucleares?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿GUERRA NUCLEAR?
¿Os imagináis que dentro de 20 años el
presidente de España sea Andrés Iniesta?
Bueno, pues en Pakistán el primer ministro
es el hombre que llevó a su país a la victoria
en el Mundial de Cricket: IMRAN KHAN.
Al igual que sus predecesores, IMRAN KHAN
intentó mejorar las relaciones con la India.
Y justo en ese momento, los terroristas de
Jaish-e-Mohammed organizaron la peor masacre
en Cachemira en los últimos 30 años.
Y ahí es cuando el Primer Ministro Indio,
Narendra Modi, dijo:
“A ver Pakistán… ven aquí que te voy
a decir una cosa.
Aquí en la India estamos rifando una ristra
de hostias así de grande y tienes todas las
papeletas”.
En otras palabras, que por primera vez en
décadas, India bombardeó territorio pakistaní.
Es decir, no atacó Cachemira, que es lo habitual
en estos casos… sino directamente Pakistán
¡Pero atentos por que aquí viene lo realmente
importante!
En estos momentos, la India ha hecho un movimiento
crucial en este duelo mexicano.
Y ese movimiento tiene nombre: INS ARIHANT,
el “destructor de enemigos”.
El submarino nuclear INS Arihant completa
su patrulla; la triada nuclear del país en
operación
¿Recordáis que Pakistán podía usar sus
armas estratégicas para destruir los silos
nucleares de la India?
Pues bien, los indios son conscientes de eso.
Y por eso, han comprado submarinos nucleares.
La ventaja de un submarino nuclear es que
tu arsenal atómico ya no está en un punto
fijo sino que lo puedes tener moviéndose
continuamente y bajo el agua.
Es casi imposible de encontrar y de destruir.
Y eso explica que el ejército pakistaní
se pusiera tan nervioso.
Y aquí es cuando casi todos los medios de
comunicación empezaron a hablar de una posible
guerra nuclear… pero ¿Es posible?
La verdad es que no lo parece.
Para empezar, aunque la India atacara territorio
pakistaní, se limitaron a bombardear campos
de entrenamiento terroristas.
Es decir, que no llegaron a cruzar las líneas
rojas de lo que Pakistán considera una invasión.
Así que ¿Cuál fue la respuesta de Pakistán
al bombardeo?
Pues una pequeña escaramuza aérea en la
India.
Pero, seamos honestos, los últimos que quieren
una guerra nuclear son Pakistán.
Y si no, mirad lo que dice uno de sus anteriores
presidentes.
"Si atacamos con 1 arma nuclear, India podría
terminar con nosotros con 20", dice Pervez
Musharraf
Todo esto explica Pakistán no tardó ni 3
días en devolver al piloto indio que fue
capturado en su territorio.
Es más, es que si Pakistán tuviera la más
mínima tentación de volver a atacar, India
ha dejado las cosas muy claritas.
India despliega submarinos nucleares y un
portaviones en el mar Arábigo para disuadir
"aventuras" de Pakistán
Vamos, que de nuevo, ninguno de los dos países
está realmente dispuesto a un enfrentamiento
nuclear real ¿Entonces?
¿Quién sale ganando de todo esto?
Pues… nada más y nada menos que el Primer
Ministro Indio, Narendra Modi.
Porque sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la India acaba de celebrar elecciones presidenciales.
Y Modi ha vuelto a arrasar.
Pero de eso vamos a hablar en un próximo
vídeo.
Porque, como os podéis imaginar ¿Cómo no
íbamos a cubrir las elecciones indias en
VisualPolitik?
Mientras tanto, la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que India y Pakistán pueden llevarse
bien algún día?
¿Podrá recrudecerse este conflicto después
de las elecciones?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos al canal para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.